[Applause]
here's what's coming up on this week's
swipe Twitter's CEO tells us there is a
middle ground in the rau over encryption
I've witnessed the augmented reality
platform builders the future of surgery
and in our games review we've got an
upcoming release nostalgia fans are
going to love
welcome to swipe from a hospital this
week and once you see why we're here you
could say we're in two hospitals and
it's got nothing to do with
teleportation before we get to that
though we're going to hear from one of
the biggest names in tech Twitter's
chief executive Jack Dorsey was in
London this week where Tom got to catch
up with him about one of his other
ventures Square and a key topic of the
moment security the businesses of the
future like this laser cutting and 3d
printing lab in central London rely on a
networked world Jack Dorsey is the chief
executive of both Twitter and off square
a mobile payments company launching in
the UK squares systems use encryption to
keep customers and businesses financial
information safe after the westminster
attack Home Secretary amber rod called
on companies including whatsapp to give
government access to encrypted services
Dorsey said that a compromise with
Silicon Valley is possible I think
there's an absolute middle ground I
think it really has to be measured by by
the individual and how they're how
they're using it I think you know as we
talk about security we also need to talk
about accountability and about
transparency and how things work we you
know at square we're very proactive
about our outreach to government
agencies to make sure that we ensure
more safety across the board and an
encryption is a really really important
part of that do you think Twitter
doesn't get enough job but we're moving
extremist terrorist content I think you
know we've definitely led the industry
than that but there's always more work
to do and the question is how do you do
this at massive
scale and that's where you know using
more technologies like machine learning
can really help but I think Twitter has
a pretty great record
in this regard but we're always looking
to make sure that we have the right
partnership with the government to
understand what the needs are in to
really push the other problem which
you've highlighted is abuse on the
platform is that an approach that can be
helped by technology as well oh
absolutely you know we made safety the
number one priority as a company on the
platform and a lot of that has to do
with how we've applied technology and
and we're giving people controls to
report any sort of targeted harassment
or abuse companies like Square and
Twitter have been rushing into the
future more and more government wants to
apply the brakes
Tom Cheshire sky news stay with us
still to come we'll be joining a patient
as he goes for surgery but there's a
tech twist it's coming right up after a
roundup of this week's tech news samsung
has launched its latest flagship
smartphone with a bigger screen and no
physical home button the South Korean
tech giant's hope in the s8 can help
rebuild its reputation after be
exploding phones fiasco last year when
battery problems led to a withdrawal of
the note 7 the smart home systems
competition is intensifying Google's
announces due to launch its contender in
the UK on April the 6th Google Home is a
voice-controlled smart speaker that will
rival Amazon's echo and a man paralyzed
for eight years has had his arm and hand
brought back to life with the help of
thought control technology scientists
planted two electrodes in bill Kosovars
brain to record activity and generate
signals to stimulate his muscles
stick around for our games review in
just a few minutes we've got what could
be the hardest game you've ever played
before that though let me explain why
I'm now in scrubs
you see we're at Watford General
Hospital with a patient who's about to
have a skin cancer operation but the
surgeon leading his operation isn't here
he's at another hospital over 15 miles
away ma hello hello we don't have to see
tablets in operating theatres what are
you about to do you're going to have an
operation on a lovely patient Edward
you're going to remove a skin cancer
from his face and as this will result in
a defect on his face we have to design a
flat which is an operation to move some
of the tissues on his face to go into
the defect to close it this tablet will
livestream the whole procedure to
another surgeon with specific expertise
in this kind of operation this is an
interactive system where he can see what
I can see and Mark the operation and
plan the surgery over at London's Royal
Free Hospital consultant mr. Mousavi
is standing by ready to lead the surgery
Edward how are you feeling good you're
not at all nervous that your surgeon
leading operation is more than 15 miles
away
no just glad to get it done really okay
if you could magnify a little bit for me
get closer to the lesion this is my pen
which I'm going to bring in this is the
area of the cancer which we're going to
remove which leaves a hole obviously
which we need to can't leave like that
okay so you're going to take skin from
the forehead to cover the area where you
now that you've got the marking strong
are you going to follow those to do the
surgery yes the augmented reality system
was created by proxy me a tech company
from the Middle East supported by the UK
Lebanon tech hub yeah I mean I can see
that perfect the platform was first used
in war zones in areas when there's
obviously conflict and local expertise
isn't available
this remote directing of medical care
can be life-saving
now it's helping train students at the
Royal Free and it's claimed it has the
potential to speed up the NHS referral
system cutting the time it takes to get
to see a specialist so you can have a
patient come in with a broken leg yeah
you could take a photo of it both or a
video if I wanted to as well yeah and
then using they send it to the right
specialist
yes yeah ii hear loud and clear how
would you change this technology to make
it better so the next level of
improvement is going to be a 3d camera
which will improve the depth of the
vision do you feel like I do I do
because I can see it's very clearly I
can see his action and this is what I
would do in in real life the technology
is already being used in a handful of
other countries but proxy meas goal now
is to catch on with more hospitals in
the UK the future of surgery what do you
think tell us on Twitter at Sky News
wife time now for video games and Simon
has picked this week's contenders Dark
Souls 3 the ring see is the last piece
of downloadable content for Dark Souls 3
as the name suggests it takes just a new
area the Ring City where you get new
armor new weapons new clothing and most
importantly new bosses now if you've
never been into Dark Souls before the
ring city isn't going to change your
opinion on it because it's still
incredibly hard you get thrown down in
the Ring City which is the game itself
tells you is meant to be at World's End
which ties into the Dark Souls effect
and from
just got try and survive and it's a
great downloadable package and it does
everything you'd expect from a piece of
content related to Dark Souls 3 and
because developer from software is kind
of hinted this may be the last thing we
ever see from the Dark Souls series if
you love it you definitely want to check
it out
ukulele is the first title from play
tonic games and the reason you should be
so excited about it is because the
developers basically reached into 1998
grab banjo kazooie and just threw it
into 2017 and that's why in ukulele your
players are bat and a chameleon and all
you're asked to do is take down a giant
bee that stole some pages from a magical
book now as you can tell straight away
it doesn't take itself too seriously at
all but that means you're not meant to
take it seriously at all either
it's the perfect game for sitting down
with on a Sunday afternoon doing some
open-world 3d platforming partaking in
some minigames and when you fancy it
just jumping on an enemy's head you
don't even kill him
they just faint because the whole point
is it meant to be fun for all the family
in a video game world where mostly were
asked to shoot things or go on epic
adventures it's a welcome breath of
fresh air has been heroes by frozen bike
games that's coming out on the ps4 Xbox
one PC and Nintendo switch seems on
paper to be a nice little quirky game as
the title suggests you do play some
has-been heroes who have seen better
days
because today they've been reduced to
babysitting the kings two princesses and
by that I mean they have to take them to
school and make sure they get to said
school safely now that sounds like it
should be fun and that sounds like it
should be something anybody can just sit
down with and enjoy but that's not the
case because this very may well be the
hardest game you've ever played in your
life falling into the roguelike genre
which means it mixes turn-based strategy
with real play strategy all you're ever
really asked to do is take you three
characters and try and defeat the
enemies put in front of you the problem
is the enemies put on front of you
are harder than steel and even within
the first hour you're gonna be dying and
struggling and trying to figure out
what's going on I would recommend it
though if you enjoy your video games to
have a huge test of them or you just
like a challenge otherwise probably best
leave this be especially if you don't
have a lot of patience well that's it
for this week's show and don't forget
you can watch any of our episodes on
demand and all the usual places I'll be
back next week I hope you can join us
Ben - bye bye
you
[Applause]